of breath unable to speed up even more
or catch up
and overcoming the mismatch between
those seeking unemployment on the one
hand and the requirements the needs in
terms of the economy
Society businesses
that is one Element but also making sure
that young and the old find ways of
contributing and making a living in a
forever and fast changing World those
two things are
multifaceted challenges on many levels
at once
and today's event will include
distinguished speakers and organizations
from all over Europe
stakeholders both on the local and the
national level working on skills today
in view of tomorrow's challenges and
opportunities they will share
experiences good practices hopefully and
with in mind the transformational power
of upskilling and reskilling that's
today's theme
on behalf of the organizers a big thank
you to the hundreds and even thousands
of organizations all across Europe that
are the face of this European year of
skills and your audience both here and
online you will be invited to join the
discussion throughout this event
now I mentioned we are at the city de
metier that's no coincidence
is a bilingual professional orientation
Guidance Center where since 2018
foreign
work together
together also with other partners in the
field of education and Entrepreneurship
they work together to help people find
jobs or ways to change or further their
career at any given age and at any given
point in their lives
is part of an international Network
originating in Paris and now active
currently active in six European
countries since May 22 the city dementia
Brussels has participated in the
development of
otloff lifelong guidance system which
guides as mentioned people during their
entire career from Education and
Training to employment the service has
been increasing its reach with a growing
number of customers and over the last
year no surprise it has also provided
services in Ukrainian to help people who
fled the war and land it here or in
other City de metier across Europe
generates
no surprise there a great deal of
Interest both in Brussels and from
institutions abroad but enough of me
it's now time to um
turn to the official opening of this
event with a keynote speech by the
president of the European commission Ms
Ursula Van Der light from The Lion she
will introduce the theme the key theme
of skills its significance specifically
of course to the twin
Ambitions and transitions the commission
is working on the both the green and
digital Transit transformation and she
will tell us why she proposed a European
year of skills here's Miss Ursula from
The Lion
welcome to the European year of skills
Festival
I am thrilled that so many of you are
here
or connected online
education is not just a preparation for
life
but education becomes a way of life
and this is what our European year of
skills is all about
whether you're starting out in your
career I are Midway through it or you're
nearing the end
investing and training is not just the
right thing to do
smart thing to do
because our world is being transformed
by technology and by the clean
transition
and this also creates new jobs and
different ways of working that didn't
exist even yesterday
a million new opportunities for people
of all ages initiatives like the pactful
skills are bringing together
governments and businesses
industry and trainers social partners
and authorities on the ground and you
name it
only together
can we help millions of Europeans
upskill and reskill
people who like and can do their work
with them we built a Europe that is more
competitive and more resilient
and I wish you a wonderful festival and
a happy Europe day thank you
the digital transformation is happening
all around us I'm sure you've realized
in our daily lives a lot of services for
example are being apified and businesses
um and governments are trying to keep up
as much as we are with this ever
evolving development
um all of us have to catch up and adapt
though that's much easier said than done
I'm sure you agree
because if you look at the idea of
digital skills as a way of life one
might wonder if it's a realistic
objective if it's attainable really if
you know that about 90 percent of jobs
in the near future will require digital
skills fact but only
46 of people in the EU can actually
perform basic digital tasks such as
connecting to Wi-Fi for example or using
websites even
more than 70 percent of businesses see
lack of digital skills as an obstacle to
investment
so no wonder the EU decides to invest in
developing digital skills and more and
continuous investment is planned
now next you will hear from Belgium's
longest established production house
Sylvester Productions it's called its
company producing TV video
events and content
good morning to you here it's from
overscale the CEO of Sylvester
Productions and Vince yarkov senior
event producer at Sylvester Productions
good to see you thank you for joining us
Hello annalize nice to see you likewise
first thing I'm wondering I can imagine
that the pandemic it seems a long time
ago now but it's really just around the
corner isn't it or we've just turned a
corner that the pandemic forced you to
think again about how to organize work
and and what skills were needed to keep
the company running can you tell us what
you changed and how you manage that
yeah well welcome at Sylvester
Productions we are in fact a hybrid
event video and television company and
as you can see I am a big fan of herget
the Belgian author of Tintin and in his
album destination Moon he showed already
he was a real promoter in the early 50s
of reskilling and upskilling but as for
Sylvester
in the first weeks of the covet outbreak
we we had to change and we suffered a
lot we suffered a loss of about 3.5
million euro in turnover in events in
the first couple of months
but that was not something only for us
it was for the whole sector in Belgium
and in Europe but most agencies chose to
send their people on to Center staff on
technical or temporary unemployment
waiting for the covet storm to pass but
our company mission is to unite and
connect people and so we asked ourselves
how we could continue to do so and we
looked at the skills we had in our
company that were video skills that were
content making and scenario skills for
television and of course our event
skills so we asked ourselves how to
reskill to find new ways of organizing
events
and we drastically changed to digital
events that were not the teams or the
zoom sessions or webinars but real state
of the art streaming events starting
from a concept and a scenario and with a
lot of experience and interaction
exactly as the event we have having
today it meant for our event people to
learn the ABC of video and television
Dynamics and for our video people our
audio visual people to get into the
basics of event skills in the beginning
that was not so easy but we did many
many tryouts and after some weeks or
maybe a couple of months all fell into
place
but we were not completely satisfied
with the level of interaction and
experience we could achieve
and we asked ourselves how we could do
better so we asked three producers in
our company we have who had quite a
programmatic mindset uh to uh invent to
conceive such a digital platform in
which a participant could experience a
digital event as he experiences a
physical event and the result of this
all was meeple meeple was a event venue
platform a virtual event venue platform
in which the participant could really
navigate through the venue as he can do
in real life yeah in Autumn 2020 we had
all this expertise and experience and
skills on board and we could offer our
clients a wide range of possibilities to
connect people in digital events
okay so
um one of the persons it meant of course
it meant a big boost for our company not
only we organized more than 120 digital
events since Autumn 2020 we also were
awarded SME of the year in our region
and we grew in staff from 20 to 40 to
more than 40 persons one of the persons
whose skills and role in the company
changed most was Finn's Vince was a
event senior event producer fully
concentrating on physical events but we
felt immediately that he understood very
well the new needed skills so he
appointed him as one of the leaders of
this hybrid and online switch hello
Vince
can you say something more about what
the digital switch in our company meant
for you
of course well thank you again the
transition from physical to digital
events required me to adapt my
day-to-day tasks for example decorating
a stage is different from from set
dressing for a stream or recording like
we're doing right now moreover during
virtual events we do not receive the
same visible feedback on our people
experience everything unlike with with
Live Events and our team also didn't
have the right skills from the start so
we did a group effort to learn about the
ins and outs of inline online events
either by upskilling or riskilling
ourselves
um so we had some of the colleagues that
had experience in streaming games for
example we could repurpose this
knowledge into a business context other
new expertise and how to knowledge had
to be gained by either child and error
internal education and knowledge sharing
of course or just asking partners with
the right background for help
you are considered one of the
co-inventors of the meeple platform I
think it's a real example of upskilling
um well I guess our virtual event
platform meepo has been crucial in
attracting new and diverse customers as
we are not an ID or web development
company ourselves we worked with
Partners to build an online event venue
that caters to different audiences while
still being able to adapt and use our
event skills to create something unique
and engaging and now we see now post
covet we use our new skills to combine
physical and online to organize hybrid
events which we believe is a new
standard in the industry
Thank You Vince
so at least that was the change for
Vince vincharkops but of course he was
not the only person in the company whose
role changed and who had to acquire new
skills now for many of our employees we
focus on those hybrid skills when we
hire someone it's not only a video or an
event expert we focus on this hybrid
skills and that's our future
so that is our story we were very happy
to share it with you all there in
Brussels and all over Europe and you are
now very curious to hear more stories
from all over Europe thanks for
listening
thank you Hertz van oversilde and Vince
jakobs thank you for sharing that and
from my point of view a hybrid event is
much more
um fun to do with your reaction of live
audience than just online but the great
thing is that the online audience can be
drawn in and is actually out there
enjoying this as much as we are so
that's an advantage let's say that um we
were left with after the horrible
pandemic now
on to Berlin where Executive Vice
President of the commission Margarita
vesagar also wants to address us the
floor is yours Miss vestager
you can have all the ideas all the
Ambitions all the money
in the world if you do not have skills
nothing will actually materialize
today we're at a German company in
Berlin 50 years history so they have
traveled a lot
130 employees
they would help to do
um sort of the technology of the trains
making sure that the cameras are working
that privacy is in place uh they would
digitalize tracks they're also European
in their Outreach so they do a lot of
different things and obviously when
you're 50 years old well transport has
changed just unbelievably we believe in
lifelong learning because everything
always changes not just in the
construction site but also in the
technology we install we've gone through
a change from analog to digital
technology both on track and in the
transport modes and I need my employees
to be able to handle that because who
would change a really valuable employees
just for a change in technology we
actually use a number of formats to stay
trained and to stay on top of things the
first one is developed for our young
stars and our apprenticeships they use
an app to learn the content that they
need to pass their exams outside on the
construction site we also use an app to
document what we do but to keep on top
of security and safety trainings the
last thing we do is expert labs they
happen traditionally here in our old
s-bahn train where we meet with other
companies I think it's really important
to stay inspired so we work with a
number of tech startups but also older
and and well integrated companies and we
actually
work together in workshops try new
things exploring new technologies with a
good gamification Factor It's always
important to have fun at work one of the
great things that I have seen here is
that you have a YouTube channel that
will show you a specific task
so when you have to do it you can sort
of check
the YouTube video and then the minute
after you can actually do it
which means that you can translate what
you see to something tangible that you
do with your hands and in my experience
that's an excellent way of learning
skills is the key to getting things done
Executive Vice President of the
commission Margarita there now on to
Ukraine where in spite of the war people
are keeping an eye on the future they're
already shaping it preparing it as it
were Ukraine you might want to know aims
to become the most digital state in the
world it's an ambition that took root
three years ago
so it precedes the invasion of Russia
over a little a little over a year ago
the ambition still stands firm and it is
to make everyone digitally literate
to tell you more about the how and why
here is Valeria ionan she's the deputy
minister of digital transformation in
Ukraine
hi my name is Valerie and I'm Deputy
Minister for your integration at the
ministry of digital transformation of
Ukraine and I'm happy to welcome
everyone at the European Europe skills
festival and I congratulate everyone
with Europe day the ministry of digital
transformation of Ukraine was created
three years ago and is well known for
digital reforms in Ukraine as well as
for launching Dia an ecosystem of
national digital projects which is the
part of state and smartphone
presidential promise today I will tell
you more about one of the Diego system
projects Dia digital education so why
did digital education is important we in
Ukraine are working hard to make Ukraine
the most convenient digital state in the
world and it's impossible to do so if
people will have low level of digital
literacy that's why our project has two
parts entertainment platform and network
of offline hubs
for now we have created more than 100
plus Series in different topics for
different segments of target audience we
have 1.5 million registrations with 75
percentage success rate we have
developed four digigrams which are
basically tests for digital literacy
which are based on European framework
digicom 2.1 however there are plenty of
new challenges which are coming in
coming low level of digital literacy big
level of unemployment because of
full-scale Russian invasion to Ukraine
approach to consuming the information
which is constantly changing
we are changing our platform from the
digital education to the education it is
a significant step into the upscaling
and rescuing sector for internal real
estate people veterans and switchers who
must develop new skills to change their
jobs having a Workforce with the skills
that are in demand contributes to
sustainable growth leads to more
Innovation and improves competitiveness
skilled workers enjoy better job
opportunities as well as broader
possibilities to fully engage in society
as for the Innovations of the new Dia
education platform I want to highlight
four main sections the first one life
and learning second one riskelling
upskilling and employment
simulators and the fourth one the
updated computer science for Scholars
the education will also provide an
integration with job search websites and
current job offers catalog so after
finishing the educational way through
the platform users can easily get to the
list of available job opportunities
according to the chosen profession and
chosen region simulators are one of the
most Innovative Parts with effective
life experience of specialist day and
interactive selection of appropriate
situations also it's important to
mention that the platform will be
bilingual and all the content will be
available in Ukrainian and in English
the relaunch of de-education will be on
the 17th of May I just like to thanks to
Google auric and east Europe foundation
for this support our mission is to give
everyone free and convenient access to
modern education asvita.dia.gov.ua
so you get an idea now of how both
businesses and public authorities are
dealing with the digital transformation
or trying to but if you know that four
out of 10 adults and every third person
who works in Europe lacks basic digital
skills the digital transformation won't
be completed overnight and also it
raises the question what does all this
retraining and so forth mean for
individuals for people undergoing these
trajectories and taking it to heart
doing it in fact citizens all over
Europe to talk about that I've got two
guests here who will share their
experience with us welcome to Leticia
piracio from Italy Ferrara and welcome
to Sohail Hassani originally from Iran
now living and working in the
Netherlands welcome to both of you
Leticia I'm going to start with you
um you originally got a in environmental
biotechnologies in 2021 in Ferrara and
then
added on a training course ifts Junior
expert in circular economy weren't you
satisfied with the original course you
took well I was satisfied with my
bachelor because it gave me an academic
preparation but then when I was filling
my CV I realized that I didn't know what
to write under skills and they realized
their lack of practical knowledge so
instead of just continuing with the
standard university path I decided to
discover what I liked or didn't like to
do through practice or to try to work in
the job market so I was enrolled in
different employment agencies and then
one of them suggested me to enroll in
this ifts course and I really liked it
because it had practical method and also
it was fully funded by the amino Romania
region and different entities including
the hydro materials and the EFS and also
European money is what you're saying was
invested in yeah and it was totally
accessible for me yeah yeah and one
thing I really liked and I think it's
the most powerful tool that this course
gave me was the intervention of
different experts so I could understand
their stories and their paths in order
to give me a lot of inspiration and this
was a game changer for me to enter into
the job market and work as a project
manager like I'm doing now yeah you seem
very happy with that choice and change
uh or extra at its track in your career
Sohail Hassani very different story you
came from Iran to the Netherlands
um what did you have as a degree when
you left Iran
I had a bachelor degrees in Electro
technical engineering but I also took a
course in web designing okay and then
you arrive in the Netherlands how easy
was it or not to find a job with your
degrees and capacities well I came to
Netherlands as a refugee so at the
beginning was not so easy but also then
afterwards after my resident permit I
started applying for jobs and then at
some point I realized I don't have the I
don't have enough skill or experience
which is required in the market so then
that's then when I started looking out
for schools or courses that was possible
there and then I heard from a friend
from makeit work which is from the
Amsterdam University of applied science
and then I was like oh it is exactly
what I was looking for okay and what did
they offer you what did they
display that you needed uh first of all
the the first thing that was very
interesting uh there was a sort of very
interesting uh process of applying but
one of the very first things before when
starting to study we had an event called
the employer's market so there we had
interviews with actual employees people
who were looking for people who could
possibly have a skill so even before
starting my studies I already had a job
so that was for me a relief then that's
a feeling that you have after your
studies when you're done with studying
and you're like what now the big black
hole Yeah that stress wasn't there
anymore so I could just focus on my
studies and like just focus on Skilling
up quite a relief still you you are both
enthusiastic about what you experienced
but do you have any suggestion for
making this kind of training even more
accessible or better still from your
experience from my experience I think
that for example the employment agency
suggested me discourse because I didn't
know its existence so I would suggest
even to already try to share the
availability of these courses during
high school and also to promote this
throughout universities and to make more
of these courses because this was like a
first trial but then I think that my
peers would really enjoy to have a moral
discourses around okay and you one more
suggestion making it more widely known
but also yeah sort of the same because
when I started this I heard it from a
friend and every time I was talking to
my friends about what I'm doing they
were very curious about like where is
this how does it work so I think not
many people know about this option so if
the marketing would be better or you
know the what would be more spread that
would help a lot of people to find this
because this is a very great opportunity
to people upskill or rear skill okay
thank you very much for sharing your
stories with us Leticia piras and Sohail
Hassani thank you so much
um we are moving on because or maybe not
yet because I I can imagine that some of
you have a similar story
um you might want to share or have a
skilled Journey so to speak so if you
feel like sharing it go go do go to
Twitter and use the hashtag hashtag
European year of skills and you can
learn from each other who knows
so far now for digital transition
um that chapter we close now but we move
on to the green transition It's a small
world word rather green transition but
it has a very huge impact it certainly
poses one of Europe's biggest challenges
possibly also opportunities for the
future
and to introduce some talking points and
ideas about a green transition we turn
to Sweden currently holding the
presidency presidency of the Council of
the EU of course and a climate neutral
economy will require a fundamental
transformation in the job market is the
idea now new jobs will be created in
areas such as Water Supplies sewage and
waste management but also in
construction and electricity it is
estimated that 1.5 million additional
jobs will be created in those areas by
2030.
the Swedish minister of Education sent
this message
good afternoon everyone and greetings
from Stockholm Sweden Sweden
I'm very glad that the European year of
skills is now launched and we're happy
to do so during the second half of our
presidency of the Council of the
European Union
I'm also sure that upcoming Spanish and
Belgium presidences will manage the
European year of skills in an excellent
way
in times of the green and digital
transition a skilled Workforce is more
important than ever
the value of Education in the efforts to
achieve the twin transition cannot be
emphasized enough
this will ensure better matching to the
labor market needs enable the
Transitions and enhance the European
Union's future competitiveness
everyone should be given the chance to
keep up with new knowledge requirements
placed on the labor market no one should
be left behind
within the battery sector an estimated
three to four million jobs will be
created in the coming years
many different skills and competencies
are needed not only engineers
in the film we are about to see we will
meet Angelica who decided to re-skill to
become an automation Operator just one
of the sector-specific skills needed in
the emerging battery storage Industries
we should use the European year of
skills to further build the commitment
from the member states
and from the social Partners to up and
reskill our Workforce
this is also why we during the Swedish
presidency have put skills on the agenda
for several of our meetings
finally I wish you good luck with the
remaining parts of this event and I'm
full of expectations on what the
European year of skills will bring us
thank you
and thank to you Mr person now A Greener
and a cleaner Europe may be worthy cause
and possibly a future proof project
but it still poses quite a number of
practical challenges for example and it
was mentioned by Mr person the storage
of green energy so far still needs a lot
of work in developing the appropriate
Battery Technology For example and in
the next video
you will be introduced to the alliance
for Batteries technology training and
skills to the European battery Academy
in Belgium the automotive skills
Alliance in czechia and Prime batteries
technology in Romania it's an
international collaboration between a
number of businesses and organizations
looking for what you might call sort of
a holy grail of uh for a Greener future
and very much also requiring an answer
to the specific skills shortage here's
the video
a new Industrial Revolution is taking
place and it's green it's zero emissions
it's electric last year saw records
broken in measurements of greenhouse gas
concentrations sea level rise ocean heat
and ocean acidification these markers of
climate change highlighted the needs to
achieve carbon neutrality and constrain
global warming to avoid the worst
consequences of climate change since
energy including industry Heating and
transport accounts for 73 percent of all
emissions there's an urgent need to
expand the use of Renewables such as
solar and wind one major problem however
is reliability while sunlight and winds
don't always reach solar panels and wind
turbines our need for electricity to
power our cars handheld devices homes
and so much more
constant that's where storage
Technologies such as batteries can make
a big difference batteries can provide
Renewable Power in a stable form
eliminating any disturbances that
intermittency might cause the growth of
acceptance and use of renewable energy
and battery storage is impacting the job
market and the need for a trained
Workforce to design manufacture
integrate and maintain these
Technologies well scaling up a factory
towards gigawatt hour level one of the
major problems that we are facing is
getting the right talents so we need an
average between 90 to 100 new people
working in our factories for eight
gigawatt hour that we create new
projects across the value chain are
expected to create between three and
four million direct and indirect jobs
over the next few years the industry
requires a diverse range of skills from
engineering and Manufacturing skills
chemistry data science to
troubleshooting Diagnostics and repair
before I started automation operator
education here at looks 2020 I worked
eight years in a grocery store here in
Charlottesville
this education is calculated to be as
short and effective as possible so it it
was a great concept and it suits me
super
the easiest way I learn is when I
combine the Practical and theoretical
exercises together
a huge piece of the puzzle was of course
our great teachers
they gave support to everyone even when
it was a class widespread of knowledge
new Jump rolls emerge such as battery
material Engineers cell design engineers
and battery test technicians that
require training in sector-specific
skills and the shortage of a skilled
Workforce is a major challenge in fact
there is such an acute Workforce
shortage that 71 percent of CEOs said a
skills shortage is now their most
significant business challenge in short
this means that approximately 800
000 workers will need to be trained
upskilled or re-skilled by 2025 to meet
this demand thanks to multiple funding
streams from the European Union Europe
is ahead of the curve the roads to a
green future for Europe supported by a
suitably skilled Workforce has already
been paved with new collaborations
between albats EIT Inno energy the
automotive skills Alliance the Europe
European battery Alliance and many more
we call it a partnership between the
companies because we can we can develop
the programs that we want to use for our
for our colleagues we can also use
Romanian language and we can also
promote new technologies and new
curricula for our programs such as
energy storage systems or energy
management systems and so on they are
already building on success stories by
jointly delivering learning content and
training programs in multiple languages
available to training providers across
Europe thereby drastically reducing the
cost and time to upskill and or reskill
workers across the continent
[Music]
I did the day I got the offer that
Norwalk wanted me on board
it's the year of skills and where
upskilling and reskilling for a future
ready Workforce visit any of our
Coalition partner websites to learn more
[Music]
and one takeaway from this video is if
you ask me that great teachers can make
all the difference in a life
now so far we've heard from businesses
and public authorities dealing with
digital transformation we've heard from
EU citizens they're both over there
about their reskilling trajectory and
we've discussed some aspects of green
transition now it's time to delve into
who should be could be and will be
attracted and trained and how to make
these jobs old ones changing into
different ones or new ones coming into
existence attractive and feasible
for people for people looking for a job
whatever their age or background or
wherever they are from because
attracting skills from outside the EU is
vitals will come as no surprise to you
um Europe's population is aging as
mentioned before by various speakers
the EU also has to deal with labor
shortages and skill shortages
in sense to now right now as we speak in
Greece European commission vice
president Margarita skinas is ready to
share his insights and ideas good
afternoon Mr stinas I can see you are in
good company there what is your take on
why the EU needs International talents
[Music]
in a life
over there above their reskidding
trajectory and we've discussed some
aspects of great transition
now it's time to delve into who should
we contribute
would be attracted and trainings and how
to make these
H or backgrounds or wherever they are
from because attracting skills from
outside the EU is the vitals will come
it's no surprise to you uh Europe's
population is aging as mentioned before
um by primary speakers
um the human also has to deal with the
labor shortages and distilled shortages
good afternoon
[Music]
good afternoon good afternoon from
Athens
I hope you can hear me
we can hear you loudly it is a fantastic
moment here in Athens we're surrounded
by more than 1 000 young people trainers
students learners
celebrating this dual celebration of
Europe day and the launch of the
European year of skills
for the first time the discussion on
skills needs to move from Diagnostics to
action
and this is the moment the European year
is a fantastic opportunity a platform
that would allow us to bridge these
skills mismatch
we need to do it we have the money we
have the resources we have the political
will we have the blueprint
but we will never make it unless we also
include in our policy mix some sort of
organized labor Mobility
Europe needs to attract Talent from
partner countries
the demographic rates is unfortunately
dramatic at the beginning of last
century Europeans we were 20 of the
world population
in the beginning of this Century where
10 of the world population and by 2050
we will be five percent
this is a compelling reason to start
organizing Talent Partnerships with
third countries with partner countries
doing it in an orderly coordinated way
matching the needs of our labor markets
the talent and the available resources
in candidate countries this is the
moment to do it and in few minutes we
will be acknowledging uh
Greeks migrants with a with a migrant
background who have been trained as far
as this this is the way the European way
thank you very much Mr skinas and we
wish you a flaws here from the audience
in Brussels
we wish you and all those young people
around you
um happy continuation of Europe they
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us here in Brussels goodbye to all
of you bye-bye
over to Adriana vezova on behalf behalf
of the digi talents project in Slovakia
tell us more about your labor migration
scheme please designed to attract new
talents to the ICT sector
[Music]
good day to everyone I hope you are
enjoying the festival I'd like to thank
two organizers for the opportunity to
present the project digitalens
concerning labor Mobility Program of I.T
professionals between Slovakia Ukraine
and Moldova we prepared the project
because Slovakia faces a silver shortage
of I.T professionals approximately 20
000 people in the project we run a labor
Mobility scheme which allows young ID
talents from Moldova and Ukraine to come
to Slovakia and work for companies in
Slovakia an essential part of the
project is capacity building through
which we train participants professional
skills before they come to Slovakia
while they are working in Slovakia and
after they return home to Moldova so
they can contribute to development about
their countries this way the project
digitalens is beneficial for all
involved countries and enable us to
contribute to transferring the knowledge
from Slovakia to Moldova and Ukraine I'm
here with one of the program
participants Corina sclifos Corina you
work for millennium the soitron group
where you started as data scientist what
was your professional path since you
joined the program at first I worked
Roofing technologies that I haven't used
before and luckily I have a really great
team that support and Coach me
thanks to them I was able to learn and
develop my skills
and they also keep me motivated for all
my journey also I'm thrilled to have
opportunity to attend the Azure data
engineer course that provide me with
Knowledge and Skills necessary to cover
Microsoft certification living and work
in a new environment
may need to develop myself skill also
now I'm able to work with different
teams with people with different
environments and succeed in various
contexts thank you and when you think of
your future in IT industry whether you
see yourself actually I would like to
establish my own startup and also I
would like to maintain connection with a
company I'm currently work for it was
nice sharing all of this with you today
good luck with the rest of the events we
will be following closely
and good luck to Karina's Cliffords with
her Ambitions for her own startup in
Moldova now from the ICT sector in
Slovakia let's move to the chemistry
sector in Slovenia the researchers in
the National Institute of chemistry in
Ljubljana are also acquiring new skills
they are working together in an
international environment and
contributing to the research agenda of
long-term importance to Europe
we are here at the National Institute of
chemistry in Ljubljana in Slovenia and
we are of course very happy to be
contributing to the launch Festival of
the European year of skills and now let
me tell you how do we contribute to
developing skills in the field of
research and innovation
we are the oldest and the second biggest
research institution in Slovenia with
almost 400 employees among which more
than 300 carry out research activities
we are especially proud of the
international dimension of our research
having around 30 researchers coming from
other U countries and an additional 30
from countries outside the EU it is very
important to us to be able to attract
the best talent from across the world
and be involved in the EU research and
Innovation program Horizon Europe our
research is oriented towards the
development of new technologies and
products relevant for the green
transition and also for health
our researchers working on
internationally important areas such as
Environmental Protection chemical
engineering materials research and some
others and what we are very proud of is
that we have an energetic team of
researchers with a lot of young
colleagues they represent around
one-third of Staff members and now let
me introduce you to one of them this is
our colleague Olivera mujanin
hi I'm Olivera from Serbia I'm speaking
today from Slovenia I'm a member of the
group for modern Battery Systems here at
the National Institute of chemistry in
Milano I'm a PhD student and I spend
most of my days working on multivalent
metal organic batteries we are working
on understand and through diligent
research we hope to gain better
understanding of these systems and
hopefully contribute to them rating
Market at some point I was fortunate
enough to be a member of the Quality
Storage European training Network
and through that Network I was able to
travel around Europe and to establish
collaborations with many academic and
non-academic Partners I spent forcing of
my PhD in Basque country in Finland and
in Italy working in one company
through the scope of marikiri network I
was able to collaborate with many
experts from Slovenia but also from with
many experts from different fields from
outside of Slovenia I was fortunate
enough to spend some time in Spain in
Finland where I learned a lot about
organic synthesis as well as microscopy
and the way that this experience
affected me is that I gained New
Perspectives on the things that I'm
working on and I also gained some
perspectives on the new fields that I
wasn't so familiar with before I started
my PhD
thank you very much Olivera you're a
proof that a professional career is a
journey of a constant learning and with
all of this I wish you a happy European
year of skills or in Slovenian
traditional Europe
goodbye and have a nice time see you
thank you Natasha and Oliveira for
sharing your stories with us
and now dear audience online and here
time for you to flex your muscles and
Shake Your Brains because I have a
couple of questions that I would like
you to answer either through the use of
a
what's it called an app the QR code
thank you or via theslido.com
application using the code you can read
on the screen it's better this way isn't
it indeed first question coming up uh
see if you were paying attention this
past hour what percentage of companies
in the EU reports difficulties finding
workers with the necessary skills you
see four options do pick one and as soon
as you've picked the right or the wrong
answer
we should see the results
I see that people are answering see here
so most of you are quite
pessimistic in fact putting it at 77
percent
and indeed it is 77 over three quarters
of European Enterprises hope to see an
upskilled Workforce
um so yes there is a um
urgent need next question
how many Europeans lack basic digital
skills according to the latest available
data
12 28 64 sorry 46 or 62.
okay
I'm glad to see that most of you were
paying attention
I did mention it indeed 46 is the
correct answer striking data
there is indeed a need to invest in up
Skilling digital skills in the European
Union must be the conclusion last
question on the objectives of the
European year of skills which of these
is not
not an objective of the European year of
skills
I'm not going to read them out I think
you can read them
and are all answers in
still coming in
okay you're quite United on that number
five
all right correct answer is indeed to
provide the uninterrupted 5G coverage in
all urban areas is not on the agenda as
far as the European year of skills is
concerned it's part though of the
digital decade agenda not the European
year of skills so thank you for joining
in that little quiz
get you all involved as it were
so
we are going to discuss how to match
what is needed to be done the job market
and on what people actually want
citizens individuals with their own
aspirations hopes and ideas of their
careers their lives
in the European Parliament this too is a
matter of debate and thought let's hear
from Lucas furlas member of the EP And
the reporter for the European year of
skills decision and Dragons
MEP as well and chair of the committee
on employment and social Affairs over to
the European Parliament in Brussels
hello everyone from the European
Parliament in Brussels I'm very glad to
have here here with me Mr Drago
spritzlaru the chair of the committee on
employment and social Affair And the
reporter of the European year of skills
Mr furlas
a crucial role on the file of the
European Euro skills during the
negotiations from the beginning of the
procedure until the official adoption by
the plenary in March so let's start with
Mr furlas Astera Porter of the European
year of skills could you please list the
most important priorities for you this
year thank you for the invitation
the European hero skills is a great
opportunity for every European it is
focused on upskilling energy Skilling
personally my main priority is to reach
every European citizen in every Europe
every corner of Europe and provide them
with these opportunities
for me it is very important to raise
awareness and communicate the message
that we must be ready to provide
European citizens with the right skills
to face digital and green transition
we aim to connect universities with
markets and markets with societies
your vision is how can we localize
skills and ensure that the work in the
European year of skills will reach
private companies education institutions
of course the third sector and
stakeholders
it is really crucial that European Arab
skills would not be seen just a brussel
initiative we need to have our citizens
the direct experience of the impact of
the European AF skills in their
local
aspects of their life we need to have
entrepreneurs understanding how this
works we need to have the Civil Society
and everyone understanding that the
European skills is for each and every
citizens wherever they are in the
European
there are a couple of things that we
have imagined for the year of skills for
first of all this idea of a local pact
for skills we need these strategies at
local level to respond the regional
needs and the local needs and close the
gap between the skill shortage and the
better job offers this should be the
format in which we create skills in the
next period then we have the
hand Vietnamese says the European
commission have put it more recently and
we need this
is for training knowledge exchange and
sharing Innovative practices between
stakeholders and we with this idea of
incubating skills for the twin
transitions with the with the climate
change and the digital transformation as
well this format of One-Stop shops we we
use it in the past but right now it's
important to use it for skills
development last but not least and this
is a very important issue for us in the
European Parliament we have been
witnessing the European year of Youth
last year and I think that the legacy of
that year should be felt in the European
area of skills young people should be at
the Forefront of our efforts so that
they will be
to participate in this ambitious process
of transforming the EU so it's important
the brazilizing the whole thing and to
pass the message Brussels will still
play a role but that is important is to
be sure that we are not just going to
keep it in here in an ivory Tower in
Brussels but instead to be sure that
it's all over in the union and it's
about people
even in people so Mr furlas what is the
main message that you would like to send
to the European citizens we have to
learn from our
my message is clear from Mother Day one
no one
should be left behind this is a message
I want to send this includes students
employees people in remote areas with
people with disabilities and vulnerable
groups our goal is to reach everyone and
build a competitive Europe with
confident professionals let's make it
happen
last
so how can European year of skills help
our EU labor market to be competitive as
Mr Fula said beyond 2023
I think that my dear colleague Lucas
from has mentioned the the breed that we
have from the European Parliament for
inclusiveness to be sure that no one is
going to leave behind but at the same
time there is a balance because we would
like also a competitive Union and
fighting an investment in investing in
skills is just like that this is the
momentum for rethinking the way we
invest in people in our human capital
and implementing these new approach is
that correspond to our changing needs
and as everyone is aware right now we
are preparing for a new industrial
strategy the so-called Net Zero
industrial strategy where one of the
fundamental chapters is the skills
chapter we might be in a transformation
that is going to take Everyone by storm
and not have people to
deliver it and that's very
very important and we will fight
from the European Parliament position to
be sure that competitiveness includes
this kind of investment in skills last
but not least there will be plenty of EU
funding communities and we need to be
sure from the parliament side as a
scrutiny function that we deliver that
the money will reach
the the right people the right
entrepreneurs the right local
authorities so that the investment in
skills is going to be put until 2024
free and Beyond I would like also to
mention the fact that we are not talking
about you know things that we can spread
here and there in fact we are talking
about ecosystems we are talking about
sectorial ecosystems we are talking
about raw materials ecosystems about
Innovation ecosystems so it's very
important to involve especially smes and
businesses in co-creation process on
this one and I would I would dare to say
that the objective is right now even
more pressing than before this is not
this is as usual we have actually
managed multiple prices at the same time
so investing in people earning skills is
a crucial thing for the future
thank you both of you and let's make it
happen thanks
some critical and self-critical
suggestions from the European Parliament
there one thing is learning from your
mistakes always a good idea
and also not leaving anyone behind and
last but not least not organize a year
of skills top bottom but bottom up so
thank you to Mr fulas and pilsaro for
the input now principles and ideas are
one side of the coin practical
implementation is another and it often
depends on the context
as well in Bath County
e-service is an organization that takes
Civic engagement to Heart
you will hear from them how they managed
to integrate over 50 employees into the
labor market
[Music]
foreign
and from Basque County back to Brussels
where I'm pleased to welcome two new
guests Brenda Godoy and Alvaro Ferreira
are here to share uh with you their
experiences with retraining and
re-skilling welcome both of you uh
Brenda Godoy I'm going to start with you
originally from Argentina currently
living and working in Holland you
completed a degree in Argentina before
you moved to the Netherlands was it a
degree that allowed you to easily find a
job
I studied chemical engineering in
Argentina and when I moved to the
Netherlands I found it pretty hard to
find a job I did not speak the language
I had no contacts and I also had and
diagnosed ADHD which made it really hard
to apply the jobs and all those things
so no it was not easy to define a job
but you are here because you found a way
to a job how did that go what tour did
you take
well after applying to some jobs I
started losing confidence in myself and
yeah I didn't really know what to do
with my career but I didn't know that I
was going to need the language so I
focused on that and when I felt
confident enough still work in progress
but
um I learned it enough that I could
retrain and I did a program called make
ID work where I retrained into software
engineering and that's what I'm
currently doing for the Dutch Chamber of
Commerce okay but use how did you hear
about this retraining opportunity my
former boss uh introduced me to the
programs okay and you are doing
something else entirely now how do you
feel about that do you still miss being
an engineer I am an engineer I'm a
software engineer now I absolutely love
what I'm doing so it depends on how you
look at it but you seem very very happy
with that thank you for sharing that
with us I also heard you say it's not
easy and you can easily lose confidence
if you're not invited or given the
opportunity to actually flex your muscle
use your degrees and your knowledge and
you overcame that obviously I
welcome to YouTube
and I should say we're going to do this
in Portuguese it's not because you
cannot understand or hear what we have
to say to each other but it's more
comfortable that way and then I'll
translate uh in between
um
foreign
[Music]
among others but not feeling like he was
realizing his total potential
um being his best possible self talking
to family and friends
um he realized he could actually retrain
um
foreign
because of this European funded program
is a
um
[Music]
oh did you get that yeah he cuts the
hair of Cristiano Ronaldo that's where
he ended up
speaking of a career change
and very very happy with that
um yeah can you imagine
retraining again do you need to as a
Caballero
[Music]
um
okay so this is not the end of the road
some new things may come along
um but it is a dream fulfilled at the
moment I want to thank you both very
much for joining us and sharing
so following this um starting event of
this European year of skills and
throughout the whole year discussions
between employees and employers social
partners and businesses between policy
makers and entrepreneurs will continue
and sometimes as the world works this
will lead to clashes but hopefully
sometimes also it will lead to
collaborations
at times of transition
impact and involvement is on everyone
now as you may remember from the speech
by Ursula vanderlaya working together is
one of the most important themes
um in her view of this event and um of
the whole year of skills
the ambition is to upskill and reskill
240 million workers in Europe now one of
the EU initiatives aimed at fostering
industry and sector-wide collaboration
is The Pact for skills currently 18
large Partnerships and 1500 members
you will see two examples
First We Take a look at members of the
energy intensive large-scale partnership
working together to learn new skills
attract talent and make Europe greener
[Music]
a society with a modern competitive and
resource efficient economy that achieves
zero net greenhouse gas emissions by
mid-century to enable this
transformation a human-centric strategy
is needed to develop a competent
specialized and multi-skilled Workforce
the European Erasmus Plus School funded
steel skills Alliance Essa and the
skills Alliance for industrial symbiosis
by a size have implemented effective
solutions for this crucial task
upskilling and attracting new Talent is
a matter of competitiveness for still
and other process Industries thus skills
agilities needed for the workforce to
successfully perform in winter jobs and
to deliver the green transition so the
blueprint's key role is to identify what
new skills are needed to deploy
industrial symbiosis the capitalization
digitalization of the process industry
and other Innovations of processes
the European steel technology platform
considers work for their government
skills and social Innovation to be as
important as technology
The Joint efforts of the stakeholders
and the regional and National ecosystem
to implement a European human-centric
strategy are reflected in Innovative
learning Solutions and new
qualifications
Redemption of skills qualification and
competencies is key to make the green
transformation successful
since some time we started to answer the
question how to support the
transformation by adapting the
vocational education and training
procedures
as the in-company training curricula of
the Dual system in Germany is
technological and methodological neutral
we digitalize the in-company training
practices we provide tablet computers
for all new apprentices with access to
an e-learning platform the apprentices
can flexibly and individually shape
their way of learning without any doubt
hydrogen-based steel making is the way
forward to decarbonize the industry we
developed an additional qualification to
be added within Apprenticeship Training
with all relevant Regional stakeholders
we developed the hydrogen qualification
including exam regulation issued as an
ordinance by the Chamber of industry in
duisburg
the transformation is just beginning and
more public and private organizations
need to come together to make concrete
commitments to upscale and reskill the
sector's current and future Workforce
that is why the Essa and Spire size
alliances are joining forces in pack for
skills with a large-scale partnership
energy intensive Industries the
alliances continue to make progress in
the digital green and social
transformation of the European
Industries
[Music]
and moving on to the Netherlands you
will witness an exchange between young
geronimous
and some Dutch students about their
project aiming to address biodiversity
it's an example of another European
partnership the center of vocational
Excellence the European platform for
urban Greening funded by Erasmus but
they will tell you all about it
themselves
hi everybody it's a pleasure to join you
from the Netherlands for the European
year of skills Festival as we speak the
very first
International Urban Greening week is
taking place
simultaneously in Finland and the
Netherlands the event features over 30
students and teacher staff
from all over Europe
it's part of the European platform for
urban Greening one of the first centers
of vocational Excellence that are
co-founded by the European Commission
I'm here with Heidi karmeling who is
Factor livable green cities at your
further College in Houghton Heidi
what are we doing this week students are
working on real life challenges and in
the meantime they also work on their
skills for example their personal skills
are working in international cooperation
with other students and learning English
and the skills specific regarding to
Urban Greening are biodiversity climate
adaptation and well-being in
relationship to Green how it's going
what have you learned so far
and what impressed you most I think what
impressed me the most was that we were
able to do some cooperation with the
biggest Landscaping Company in
Netherlands and how
how much they like invested time on us
on this
on this trip they gave us like multiple
days and multiple hours to just tell
about their work and what they are doing
in green infrastructure and Landscaping
and it was really like it just great to
see I'm also here with Larson Hinkle
who's manager Innovation at the Royal
Pringle hoop the reason that we as a
company are joining the urban winning
week is that as a company we are working
in urban Greening projects we are
working in a urban city environment and
this is a very complex environment as a
landscaping company we need to be very
Innovative in these environments we need
to face challenges every day and we need
skilled workers for that the urban
Greening week is a collaboration that we
are engaging in with schools but also
with our employees and with the
municipality
and we're together we work on tackling
these challenges
we hope you got a nice impression of how
we are working on skills in the green
sector
[Music]
I think we can say yes we did thank you
very much young and others from the
Netherlands now we are going to hear two
women working in the care sector and as
you probably all know if there is one
sector in need of hands
concrete hands and skilled hands at that
it is the sector of hospitals Elderly
Homes for the elderly and so on now you
will hear from Angelica who's a nurse in
an elderly care center in Sweden and
from liver who organizes care in Belgium
hi everybody my name is Angelica and I
work as an assistive nurse with the
elderly I provide care for the elderly
in the comfort of their own home and my
main tasks include helping with personal
hygiene medication and social activities
like going for walks and such
I have an assistant nurse degree but my
job requires annual education and
examination to ensure our skills and
knowledge are up to date
we get tested on our medication skills
lifting and so on
besides this we also get training in
fire safety protocol to help keeping our
clients safe
our social Partners the employers and
the union together have made it possible
for assistive nurses to work part-time
while studying at hofspade with full
salary compensation to get their degree
one of the main challenges that we face
for the next decade is certainly finding
uh and keeping staff as we Face already
a shortage at this moment
and the work in our sector has changed a
lot the last let's say 10 years
and supporting people with disabilities
in having a good quality life
uh
whatever their support need is whatever
their family context is or social
contexts requires really a lot of skills
from the support workers
um
and the competences to deal with
person-centered care and the flexibility
that's needed there but also to deal
with
constant societal change and the
flexibility that's needed there are very
important in the work that we do
heartfelt stories there and on to
Portugal where the textile and clothing
industry finds ways to upskill and
reskill people in order to keep up with
changes in the sector
and tintex colleagues from Portugal are
working together with eurotics in The
Pact for skills textiles clothing
leather and Footwear partnership
concentrations
[Music]
foreign
reduction
Orange
for myself
[Music]
foreign
the workforce people citizens in the
European Union wanting to realize their
full potential else as Alvaro mentioned
earlier
ladies and gentlemen dear all we are
nearing the end of this opening session
of the European year of skills
um it's incidentally no coincidence that
it's held on Europe day today the 9th of
May and in order to highlight the idea
behind that choice that decision a last
tour the Horizon is fitting
we will first go to latia where where
sorry while skills are Central to the
Europe Day celebrations in Riga today
the partners of the State education
development agency and commission's
representation we're keen to show to you
skills development in Malta a small town
in logical the Eastern region so yes
indeed
the year of skills also goes local
[Music]
tornado
tutor
[Music]
foreign
is it safe
[Music]
thank you
a clip that shows that vocational
training and education is Cutting Edge
if you ask me
and last but not least we go to
Luxembourg to connect with another year
of Day celebration venue and more
special guests of the festival luxembu
do you hear us
they are ready I don't know if they hear
us they are very ready
we have to check the connection
this is what happens when you do a live
event hybrid it's part of the job I can
go on for hours if I if I have to keep
it in the air I do I hope not but you
never know
ladies and gentlemen in Luxembourg yes
we see you you're online
I think they started I'm gonna show
can we get sound from Luxembourg
there's one in a bachelor in applied
information Technologies and one master
in technopreneurship so Claudine can you
tell us a little bit about what
motivated you to do this training
courses
hi well
um first of all I did the duty a diploma
of in technology University also in
computer science in 2003 till 2007 and
already there I wanted to do a bachelor
but the bachelor was no opportunity
because there was none in uh evening
courses so when I saw that the bachelor
now was proposed by lifelong Learning
Center in collaboration with University
of Luxembourg I took the opportunity to
do the bachelor
and then I was so into learning that I
also wanted to have a master so I did
this master in technopreneurship that's
about standardization and it was really
new we were the first one to do it
and it also gave me new job
opportunities it opens doors even if you
are 40 years 50 years it always opens
doors so do it
wow that was so that was a really good
choice for you to take interest in
computer science so early on so you
maybe have a message to pass to our
audience uh to all people who still
hesitate to do to take up a training of
course whatever training interests you
whatever you want to do if you would
learn it for yourself if you want to
learn it from more job opportunities go
for it only the sky is the limit you're
never too old to do training course you
see I'm never too old
to learn something new to go into
something new just do it
it's it's everything is possible for
everybody
but that's a really nice message to all
of our audience that people who maybe
are still hesitating to uh to take the
step and to do lifelong learning
Commissioners uh how do you react to uh
I think that's a message she gave now
for the year of skills that's really the
message we need first the motivation is
is key but also the opportunity you you
have to get because I think we have to
make sure that everybody who wants to
have lifelong learning who wants to
rescale and upskill gets the right
opportunity I think that uh as uh she
said now she got the opportunity and she
took it so I think to all the Europeans
the world is changing but there are a
lot of good opportunities waiting for
you so be motivated
be uh have confidence in yourself and as
claudina said well take this opportunity
and you will be successful
um thank you commissioner so uh today is
the official launch of the European year
of skills uh what exactly is the aim of
the of the European Union of skills
commissioner can you tell us a little
bit more about that well I think we are
all aware that we need uh a change of uh
SK in in in terms of skills because of
the uh transformation in our economy uh
be it digital and you have spoken about
the digital there's also uh the green
transformation with a lot of new
technologies coming up and
um I think that your skills once
precisely first change the mindset and I
think that's the message we just got but
second also motivate companies motivate
member states motivate regions and at
the end also motivate individual
citizens that skills is the new girl you
know you have you have the opportunity
you you should have the opportunity to
invest in your own skills and I think
this is what the uh the Europe skills
should really uh amplify everywhere and
this is also on which
uh Europe's Prosperity will be built its
own people people invest in people
that's that's finally our our wealth
skills is the new goals I think that's a
nice message uh from Luxembourg to give
back uh to Brussels and enjoy your
update and the Europeans uh year of
skills thank you very much for the
contribution from Luxembourg
[Applause]
so dear all for the last hour and a half
you heard testimonies ideas principles
and practicalities about the need for
skills I think the most mentioned word
in the past hour and a half need for
skills upskilling re-skilling regardless
of age and background or where you're
from and with regard for social justice
and rights and opportunities
and in the best of circumstances without
pressure of course
it's about change with an eye on the
future and as the commissioner would
have it a Greener and digitally sound
future
it's a work in progress that may be very
clear
um hereby the opening event of the
European year of skills Festival has
come to an end but I should say it's the
beginning or sorry the end of the
beginning
um so to speak should you want to learn
more about future activities in the
upcoming year you can go to the website
and find out what's going on all across
Europe as mentioned at the very
beginning the event is also available on
YouTube should you want to re-watch
something or share it with others and
last but not least on behalf of the
organization and the initiators a big
thank you to all the contributors local
National you name it European making
this event possible sharing their
experiences and stories and allowing you
here and those watching us online on a
skills Journey across Europe so that's
it for now for here thank you very much
for being here being so attentive have a
good day and a safe journey to wherever
you're going next thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]